[Music]
[Applause]
the blind marches on
these people live with a knife to their
throat you have to believe us we'd help
you if we could
and you're helping us already
we never asked to be saved did you think
we'd thank you they'll never forgive us
we're all marked now
every time you show your faces it is we
who suffer
he better hope so
crystals take more than they give you
need to tell me that the mother crystals
are the reason the world is dying
we're talking is they won't give us a
say we'll decide our Fates another way
do you believe what I'm about to do is
wrong I was forced to kill you do it by
choice
believe in me they believe in the power
of the dominant you Can't Blame A man
who wanted to bring an end to all this
can you ever let us Stray by your blind
result and thus is
we don't need your salvation we'll save
ourselves and we'll do it on our own
terms
all right
who are we what are the dominance we are
but Mighty acts of God enough of this I
use my talents to my advantage you would
tell me there is shame in that
we shared a dream I would be the king of
the world
Darkness has taken hold of you it has
made you forget yourself I don't want to
be a monster of life
I made a promise to my friends and it is
they who will give me the strength to
end your Reign your efforts will Avail
us not
the fight we survive we enjoy we don't
need a reason
[Music]
thank you